네 이번에 bsn 꼬마빌딩 스터디
34개를 모집합니다 저희가 8년 동안
진행하면서 2,000명이 넘는
수강생과 300명이 넘는 건물주를
만들어낸 검증된 강의라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다이 강의의 특징이 전문가
집단을 연결해 드립니다 그래서 공인
중개사뿐만 아니라 세무사 건축사
시공사 대표 등 빌딩 투자와 관련된
어벤져스급 전문가를 연결해 드립니다
그리고 유튜브에서 이야기하지 못했던
실패 사례를 생생하게 다룹니다 성공
사례만 많이 듣거든요 근데 실패
사례도 정말 많습니다 그런 실패
사례를이 강의 를 들으시면
생생하게들을 수 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다 그리고 강의뿐만 아니라
현장 답사도 진행합니다 4주차 동안
진행할 예정이고 사실 현장에서
배우는게 되게 많거든요 많은 사람들이
다양한 의견을들을 수 있는 기회입니다
그래서 보통은 현장 강의 가서 되게
만족했다라는 수강생분들이 많거든요
현장 강의도 강의에 포함이 돼
있으니까이 부분도 좀 기억하시면 좋을
것 같습니다 그리고 무엇보다 수강생들
조마다 네트워크를 만들어 드리니까
거기서 배우는 것도 되게 많습니다
이런 부분을 좀 참고해서 저희
스터디를 들으시 면 정말 돈 아깝지
않고 시간 아깝지 않게 저희가 8년
동안 준비하면서 쌓아온 그런 노하우로
준비했으니까 기대하시고 신청하셔도
좋을 것 같습니다 그리고 강의 내용은
1주차 때는 제가 직접 나와서 최근에
매각된 사례라는 최근의
트렌드라지만 빌딩에 정말 기본적인 뭐
건폐율 용적률이 기본적인 내용을
가지고 강의를 진행할 예정입니다
그리고 3주차 때는 회계사 님이
나오셔 가지고 회계사님 직접 빌딩
투자를 해 보셨거든요 투자자 입장에서
세금과 관련된 내용들을 되게 알기
쉽게 강의를 진행할 예정이고 4주차
때는 저희 건축사 님이랑 시공사
대표님이 나와서 1딩 리모델링이라는
신축과 관련된 내용들을 가지고 강의를
진행할 예정입니다 그리고 4주차 때는
진행하기 전에 저희가 설계했던 건물을
직접 가서 건축사님이 이렇게 이야기해
주는 시간도 있으니까 기대하셔도 좋을
거 같고 5주차 때는 제가 또 직접
나와서 성공 사례뿐만 아니라 실패
사례를 주로 얘기할 거예요 그때 이제
수강생분들이 많이 충격을
받으시더라고요 사례가 얼마나 많은지
체감 하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그리고
건물 매입하고 난 뒤에 관리가 되게
중요하거든요 관리에 대한 내용도
있으니까 기대하셔도 좋을 거 같고
스터디 때 인사드리도록 하겠습니다